salut c'est Lucas de bruit de nature
toutes les semaines dans la grande
explication j'essaie de répondre à des
questions sur l'écologie la semaine
dernière je vous parlais des chats et
j'ai reçu beaucoup de commentaires je
vous en remercie cette semaine je me
suis demandé pourquoi face au manque
d'eau on transformait pas tout
simplement l'eau de mer en eau
potable en fait j'ai appris récemment
que beaucoup de pays le faisaient déjà
dans la France face au risque de pénurie
plusieurs pays d salent même à très
grande échelle on a aujourd'hui plus de
20000 usines de dessalement d'eau de mer
dans le monde mais ces technologie ell
inquiète ce sont des gouffres énerg
elles détruisent la vie marine à tel
point que même l'ONU a tiré la sonnette
d'alarme alors je me suis demandé
pourquoi de plus en plus de pays dessall
l'au de mer pourquoi ces procédés
inquiète je vous
explique nous sommes aux Émirats arabes
unis au sud-ouest de Dubaï vous
reconnaissez peut-être ces îles
artificielles en forme de palmier si on
zoome un peu sur ce quartier on
s'aperçoit en fait que c'est une
gigantesque usine elle détient le record
de la plus grande usine de dessalement
au monde ici à partir d'eau salé l'usine
peut produire 2 milliards de litres
d'eau douce chaque jour et 2 milliards
de litres c'est la consommation
journalière d'environ 13 millions de
français pour mieux comprendre comment
ça marche j'ai interviewé une ingénieure
hydrologue et la responsable de la
cellule eau du CNRS 97,5 % de l'eau
présente sur terre est salée donc
évidemment on a plus d'eau salée que
d'eau douce on a seulement 2,5 % d'eau
douce sur terre aux Émirats Arabes Unis
c'est déjà 90 % de l'eau potable qui
provient du dessessalement en fait le
dessalement c'est pas tout à fait
nouveau
les premières vraies usines de
dessalement elles sont construites dans
les années 1950 mais le développement
est d'abord assez lent dans les
décennies suivantes des pays comme
Israël ou les pays du Golfe voi leur
besoins en eau exploser ils doivent
approvisionner des habitants de plus en
plus nombreux mais aussi de nouvelles
activités agricoles ou industriel alors
même qu'ils sont situés en grande partie
dans des déserts ils se tournent donc de
plus en plus vers l'eau des salé il y a
des systèmes de traitement qui ont été
déployés alors
essentiellement dans des régions ou dans
des villes où on était vraiment en
manque d' dou on était sur le littoral à
proximité bah de cette ressource à
partir des années 2000 la production
mondiale explose en 20 ans elle a été
multipliée par 5 certains ont
particulièrement misé sur ces
technologies en 2019 5 pays représentent
à eux seul plus de la moitié de la
production l'Arabie Saoudite les
États-Unis les Émirats arabesunis mais
aussi la Chine et l'Espagne par exemple
Barcelone a construit une usine qui
produit chaque jour 200000 M C d'eau
pour l'alimentation en eau potable de la
popul tion 33 % qui est qui est concerné
et dans les pays arabes ça peut aller
jusqu'à 80 % 90 % de la population qui
est desservie par une eau dessalée face
au risque de pénurie le Maroc l'Algérie
la Chine l'Espagne et de nombreux autres
pays veulent continuer à déployer
massivement ces technologies par exemple
d'ici 2030 les pays du Moyen-Orient
prévoient de doubler les quantités d'eau
dessalé j'ai même découvert que
plusieurs usines ont été récemment
installé en France mais on en parlera un
peu plus tard pour l'instant je veux
comprendre concrètement comment on peut
dessaler l'eau de mer
il y a pas longtemps j'ai repensé à une
expérience qui m'avait marqué quand
j'étais petit si on met de l'eau de mer
dans un bol qu'on la recouvre d'un film
plastique un peu comme ça on met un
objet lourd juste ici si on attend
longtemps au soleil l'eau va s'évaporer
on va récupérer du sel dans le bol et
l'eau douce dans la tassque ça je me
souviens à l'époque ça m'avait
impressionné mais quand on veut faire ça
dans des quantités bien plus grandes à
l'échelle d'une ville ou d'un pays c'est
tout de suite plus compliqué deux
principales techniques ont été inventé
il y a d'abord le dessalement thermique
et ça ça ressemble peu à l'expérience du
saladier c'est faire bouillir de l'eau
l'eau salée et puis par distillation
récupérer toute la vapeur finalement en
laissant déposer le sel et en récupérant
l'eau douce qui résulte de cette
technique de distillation thermique
sachant qu'on obtient H2O donc H2O il y
a plus ces minéraux dont on a besoin
pour qu'elle soit consommée par les
popalation humaine donc il faut ajouter
certains minéraux bon dans la réalité
les circuits sont un peu plus complexes
mais vous avz vous avez capté le
principe une seconde technique ça
s'appelle l'osmose inverse et derrière
ce nom barbare c'est en fait assez
simple avec une pompe sous pression en
fait on va pousser l'eau à travers des
membranes qui vont laisser passer les
molécules d'eau tout en retenant les
selles dissous aujourd'hui le
dessalement thermique représente 25 % de
la production et l'osmose inverse 70 %
les 5 % restants c'est d'autres
techniques peu utilisé alors tout ça
c'est super sur le papier mais en réité
le dessalement c'est un désastre
écologique quand on dessale j'ai
découvert que l'eau douce c'est pas la
seule chose qu'on récupère vous vous
rappelez de ces graphiques d'un côté on
récupère l'eau douce mais de l'autre on
récupère aussi une eau super concentré
en sal on appelle ça la saumure c'est un
réel déchet auquel souvent est sont
associés des produits chimiques qui ont
participé à l'ensemble du du traitement
ce qui reste de ces de ces
samurs en général sont rejetés en mer
l'ONU a tiré la sonnette d'alarme en
2019 avec cette étude elle révèle que la
production mondiale de sa mur s'élève à
141,5 million de m Cu par jour ça c'est
bien plus que ce qu'on pensait jusqu'à
présent mais aussi bien plus que la
quantité d'eau dessalée qui est produite
en moyenne ça veut dire que pour chaque
litre de 12 produite on rejette environ
1,5 l de Saumur ces technologies pose
des des des problèmes écologiques
notamment sur les écosystèm marin
puisque les rejets de Saumur vont
modifier la salinité de la mer très
localement et impactter notamment des
espèces aquatiques très menacées comme
les herbiers de posidonie qui qui sont
déjà menacés par par d'autres activités
humaines et c'est pas tout il y a encore
une autre
préoccupation pour produire ces millions
de mètres cubes d'eau chaque année d'eau
dessalée on a besoin d'énormément
d'énergie alors d'où vient cette énergie
dans cet article Corine cabassu
professeur à Lina Toulouse explique que
moins d'un % des EAU dessalées sont
produites avec des énergies
renouvelables concrètement le
dessalement il brûle de grandes
quantités de pétrole et de gaz
historiquement ces technologies ont été
développées dans les pays arabes et en
Afrique du Nord qui qui avait accès à de
l'énergie fossile très peu cher bien
souvent on va faire appel au gaz au
pétrole et donc dont on connaît les
incidences et et les impacts plus
[Musique]
globaux résultat ça a émettit 76
millions de tonnes de CO2 en 2014 avec
des prévisions à 4 100 millions de
tonnes estimé pour 2050 et ça ça
correspond quasiment aux émissions
totales d'un pays comme l'Australie ça
m'a donné l'impression d'un cercle
vicieux on émet du CO2 pour dessaler
l'eau ces émissions aggravent le
réchauffement climatique qui à son tour
risque d'aggraver des sécheresses qui à
leur tour augmentent les besoins eau et
cetera quand j'ai découvert ça je me
suis demandé si en France aussi on
dessalait l'au de
mer ici au large de la Bretagne à 7 km
des côtes se trouve l'île de sain elle
est très isolée il dispose d'aucun accès
au dou et donc ils ont construit une
usine de dessalement jusqu'à récemment
c'était l'une des seules en France en
métropole on utilise très très peu cette
technologie puisqu'on a déjà des
ressources en eau naturelles qui sont
dans les rivières dans les acifères pour
répondre à des situations d'urgence des
usines ont aussi été installé en
Guadeloupe ou à Mayotte Guadeloupe à la
suite d'une forte tempête qui a causé
des dégâts sur les infrastructures d'eau
potable on a mis en place des solutions
de dessellement de l'eau de mer mobile
qui permettaient d'approvisionner de
continuer à approvisionner en eau
potable les populations mais en 2022
suite à des sécheresses ou des pénuries
d'autres communes se sont tournées vers
le dessalement c'est le cas de l'île de
grois de l'île de Molen ou encore de
Rogliano en Corse on n avait pas
nécessairement besoin en dehors de de
certaines îles qui justement doivent
répondre à une demande en eau
particulièrement importante en période
estivale en revanche c'est une des
questions qui est mise en avant
justement dans ce contexte grandissant
de d'interrogation quant à la
disponibilité de la ressource en nous
douce ok mais alors est-ce qu'on
pourrait imaginer un dessalement qui
détruirait moins la
planète on constate aujourd'hui dans le
monde que plus de 2 milliards de
personnes n'ont pas accès à de l'eau
potable en toute sécurité une première
solution est de se tourner vers des
technologies moins polluantes car ce
qu'on a pas encore dit c'est que les
rejets sa mur peuvent varier fortement
d'une technologie à l'autre il existe
aussi des technologies qui vont chercher
à à à trouver des filières ou des
débouchés dans les mur et c'est aussi le
cas de la consommation d'énergie dans
son article Corine cabassu note par
exemple que depuis les années 70 les
nouvelles technologies d'osmose inverse
ont permis de diviser par 10 les coûts
énergétiques on peut aussi réduire la
facture énergétique notamment par la
récupération de chaleur fatal ces
technologies sont en cours de
développement et nécessitent toujours de
l'énergie au départ cette solution de
dessellement de l'eau de mer peut être
intéressante que si on a des sources
d'énergie renouvelables mais ce n'est
pas tout pour les deux scientifiques que
j'ai interviewé il faut se demander à
chaque fois si on a besoin de consommer
autant d'eau et si aucune technique
moins polluante que le dessalement n'est
possible dessaler l'eau de mer pour
l'alimentation en eau potable est une
solution de dernier recours lorsqu'on a
déjà exploré toutes les autres solutions
notamment les économies d'eau
l'optimisation des rendements des réseau
d'eau potable et cetera et cetera
peut-être que le dessalement est adapté
à certains endroits d'autres solutions
comme la réutilisation des eau de pluie
ou le traitement des EAU usées sont
aussi des solutions pour répondre à des
besoins spécifiques un des points
extrêmement importants et peut-être la
solution c'est de se poser la question
sur les types d'usage en fonction de
l'eau disponible et non plus
d'envisager que l'eau est complètement
abondante et disponible de façon
complètement illimitée ce que j'ai
retenu en m'intéressant à ce sujet c'est
que le dessalement était loin d'être une
solution miracle il peut être utile mais
seulement dans certains cas précis et en
essayant de réduire ses impacts au
maximum
j'espère que cet épisode de la grande
explication vous a plu j'ai essayé de
pas trop rentrer dans les détails
techniques mais de pas trop survoler de
sujet non plus si vous avez encore des
questions n'hésitez pas à les poser dans
les commentaires vous pouvez aussi liker
la vidéo pour que plus de personnes
puissent découvrir ce sujet on se
retrouve très vite sur la chaîne de brut
pour traiter d'autres sujets sur les
animaux ou l'écologie et je vous dis à
bientôt